This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个爱心播客。百分之二。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析我们在光怪陆离的现代世界中培养坚韧意志、保持健康以及建立适应力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在经历之后成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。即数字“2”加“percent”，可在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客节目中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间主要探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人身穿铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这份特定的测试两次，对吗？我伪造了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。你好，欢迎回到《二十几岁的心理学》，在这个播客中，我们探讨二十几岁时的一些重大生活变化和转型，以及它们对我们心理的意义。
Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode, new listeners, old listeners. It's so great to have you here. So great to have you back for our first ever holiday special. I know it's a little bit late. I'm sorry, but I hope that we can perhaps or still have a moment of reflection and maybe it's able to help some of us who are feeling particularly lonely during this period, during the holiday period. First of all, before we jump into this discussion around loneliness, I just want to say, happy holidays, happy new year to all who are celebrating. Before we jump into the psychology, I just want to thank everyone for their support this year. It's been absolutely crazy. Like, I have no way of even describing how overwhelmed and grateful I am. It's just insane to me. much this show has grown in 12 months. I remember this time last year I felt so little motivation to
大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎新老听众收听又一期节目。很高兴能邀请到你们。很高兴你们能回来收听我们有史以来的第一个节日特别节目。我知道稍微有点晚。我很抱歉，但我希望我们或许还能有一段反思的时刻，也许它能帮助我们当中在这一时期、在节日期间感到格外孤独的人。首先，在我们深入探讨孤独这个话题之前，我只想对所有庆祝节日的人说一声节日快乐，新年快乐。在我们深入探讨心理学之前，我只想感谢大家今年对我的支持。这绝对太疯狂了。比如，我甚至无法形容我是多么的受宠若惊和感激不尽。这对我来说简直太不可思议了，这个节目在过去12个月里增长了这么多。我记得去年这个时候，我感到如此缺乏动力去
continue making episodes. I just felt really burnt out. I felt like, you know, no one really cared. But I'm so glad I continued to do it. I'm so glad that I pushed through because now I just feel yeah, so grateful. And I just thank you. Thank you a million times over. Thank you for sharing. Thank you for listening. Thank you for supporting. the show. I just cannot say it enough times. It's really been the absolute highlight of this year. Okay, now we're going to do a bit of a segue. It's not going to be a smooth segue. We're just going to jump right into what I want to talk about. And what I really want to talk about today is loneliness. I know, a bit of a crash, a bit of a plummet from all the gratitude and love. But I honestly think
继续制作节目。我只觉得真的很筋疲力尽。我心想，你知道的，根本没有人真正在乎。但我很高兴我坚持了下来。我很高兴我坚持过来了，因为现在我只觉得，是的，太感恩了。我只想谢谢你们。千言万语汇成一句感谢。感谢你们的分享。感谢你们的收听。感谢你们对节目的支持。我真的怎么说都不够。这绝对是我今年最大的亮点。好了，现在我们要过渡一下。这将不是一个平稳的过渡。我们将直接切入我想谈论的话题。我今天真正想谈的是孤独。我知道，从所有的感激和爱中跌落下来，多少有点让人措手不及，有点一落千丈的感觉。但我真的认为
it's such an important topic to discuss at all times of the year, but particularly loneliness around holidays and that unique kind of disconnection and isolation we tend to feel around the holiday season. And the reason I wanted to do this was because A, I can imagine this is a really common experience for many of us. And B, from a personal experience, I've been hanging out with my family, I'm back at my family home for the holidays, and there is always this really strange feeling I get. especially between Christmas and New Year's when I feel like overwhelmingly this sense of isolation and solitude for no apparent reason.
这是一个在一年中的任何时候都非常值得讨论的重要话题，尤其是节日期间的孤独感，以及我们在节日期间往往会感受到的那种独特的脱节感和孤立感。我想做这个节目的原因是因为，第一，我可以想象这对于我们许多人来说是一种非常普遍的经历；第二，从个人经历来看，我一直在和家人呆在一起，我为了过节回到了父母家，我总是有一种非常奇怪的感觉。特别是圣诞节和新年之间，我无缘无故地感到压倒性的孤立和孤独。
You know, I'm surrounded by my family, as I'm sure many of us and many of the listeners are, yet there is this weird, empty space that feels so prominent and hard to ignore. I honestly, this time of the year I feel more alone than ever. I'm suddenly, you know, thinking back on ever relations, I've ever had and feeling this urge to reach out to all my friends to ward off this really inexplicable loneliness. And I swear this happens to me every year around the holiday.
你知道的，我被家人包围着，我相信我们中的许多人和许多听众也是如此，然而却有一个奇怪的、空旷的空间，显得如此突出，难以忽视。老实说，每年的这个时候，我都觉得比以往任何时候都更加孤独。我突然开始（你知道的）回想我经历过的所有恋爱关系，并有一种冲动，想要联系我所有的朋友，以此来驱赶这种真正莫名其妙的孤独感。我发誓每年过节的时候我都会这样。
It's like clockwork. And I have a suspicion I'm not alone. And even if I am, well, I kind of needed to understand the reason behind this just for myself because it's been puzzling me for literally years. You know, the happiest time of the year and I've never felt more alone. So I wanted to break down some of the explanations and psychology behind why the holiday season can feel so lonely at times, especially for those of us who may be spending this season away from family. If you've had a particularly hard year, maybe you're grieving a loved one or missing someone in particular, been through a breakup, or you could just be feeling lonely for no reason at all. and that is just as valid, and it's something we'll discuss more.
就像定时器一样准确。而且我怀疑我不止如此。退一步说，即使我是一个人，嗯，我还是需要为自己弄清楚背后的原因，因为这几个字面意义上的年份里一直困扰着我。你知道的，一年中最快乐的时光，而我却从未感到如此孤独。所以我想要剖析一些解释和背后的心理学原因，为什么节日期间有时会让人感到如此孤独，尤其是对我们当中可能在这个季节远离家人的人来说。如果你度过了特别艰难的一年，也许你在为失去挚爱而悲伤，或者特别想念某人，经历了一次分手，或者你可能只是无缘无故地感到孤独。而这也是同样成立的，这是我们将进一步讨论的话题。
I think it's important, as always, to normalize not feeling normal and happy all the time. And that's especially pertinent for this time of the year, when there is a huge expectation, I think, to feel joyous and extroverted and happy and grateful. And sometimes it's really hard to feel that way, even during a normal period or a normal month, where the expectations aren't as high and the point of comparison is less prominent than it is at Christmas and it is during the holidays. So let's dissect the loneliness we often feel during the holiday season and provide some explanation for why you might be feeling this way.
我认为，像往常一样，将有时感觉不正常、不快乐的状态归为正常现象是很重要的。这在今年的这个时候尤其贴切，因为我认为人们有着巨大的期望，要感到快乐、外向、幸福和感恩。有时真的很难有这种感觉，即使在一个正常的时期或一个正常的月份里，那里的期望没有那么高，与圣诞节和节日期间相比，比较点也没有那么突出。因此，让我们剖析我们在节日期间经常感到的孤独，并对你为什么可能会有这种感觉提供一些解释。
So buckle in for our holiday episode for the year. I can imagine that many of us are feeling quite lonely, maybe a bit off, a bit strange, at this time of the year. Maybe not. Maybe it's just me. But I'm fairly sure this is a pretty common experience, just from speaking to friends and to other people around me. And I read this article whilst I was kind of researching this episode, that the holiday season and holiday loneliness is a lot more common than we think,
所以请系好安全带，收听我们今年的节日特别节目。我可以想象，我们中的许多人在今年的这个时候都感到相当孤独，也许有点不对劲，有点奇怪。也许不是。也许只有我一个人。但从与朋友和周围其他人的交谈来看，我相当确定这是一个相当普遍的经历。我在研究这一集时读到过这样一篇文章，那就是节日期间和节日孤独感比我们想象的要普遍得多，
and not just for those who find themselves physically alone as well. feeling a bit down this time of the year is actually incredibly normal and should probably be spoken about more and it happens for many reasons that we're going to discuss in a moment but before then let's do a quick refresher on the anatomy some of the background information and the things that we ought to know about loneliness loneliness i think is an incredibly personal concept and an incredibly personal idea. Each person's idea of what loneliness is, the reactions that it creates, the triggers, the reasons behind why we feel lonely is going to be completely different. And of course, there are some pretty typical ones, you know, social isolation,
而且不仅仅是对于那些发现自己身体上也独处的人。在今年的这个时候感到有些沮丧，其实是极其正常的，也许应该更多地去谈论它。导致这种情况发生的原因有很多，我们一会儿就会讨论。但在那之前，让我们快速复习一下解剖学知识、一些背景信息以及我们应该了解的关于孤独的事情。孤独，我认为是一个极其个人的概念，也是一个极其个人的想法。每个人对什么是孤独、它产生的反应、触发因素以及我们为什么会感到孤独的原因的看法，都将是完全不同的。当然，也有一些非常典型的例子，你知道的，社交孤立，
maybe you've moved cities, maybe you're separated from your loved ones that are quite common. But once again, loneliness is so subjective. and what might make one person feel really lonely and really alone is not the same as what it might be for someone else. I think there's also a key distinction between being alone physically and socially and the actual idea of loneliness. They're completely different concepts. I think someone can be physically alone and you can feel completely content. you don't feel any sadness, no pangs of loneliness, no need to reach out, and then there's someone
也许你搬到了别的城市，也许你与亲人分离，这些都是相当常见的。但再说一次，孤独是非常主观的，一个人可能会感到非常孤独和真正孤单的原因，与另一个人可能会感到的并不完全相同。我认为身体和社交上的独处与孤独的实际概念之间也存在着关键的区别。它们是完全不同的概念。我认为一个人可以身体上独处，而你可以感到完全满足。你没有感到任何悲伤，没有一阵阵的孤独感，不需要联系任何人，然后有这样一个人
who is physically alone who might feel incredibly lonely. But it's also entirely possible to be experiencing loneliness whilst being surrounded by friends and family. I think typically how we see loneliness is the absence of other people around us. But that's not always the case. There is this massive distinction that loneliness is very much a mental and a cognitive function that isn't always tied to what's in our physical environment and how many people we're seeing and the people in our lives. You can feel lonely in a massive crowded room. You can feel lonely when you are surrounded by the people that you love the most because it is a cognitive thought, a cognitive reaction to something more internal than external. I think it's also important to stay
他在身体上是孤独的，可能会感到非常孤独。但完全有可能在被朋友和家人包围的同时体验到孤独。我认为我们通常认为的孤独是我们周围缺乏其他人。但事实并非总是如此。有一个巨大的区别，那就是孤独在很大程度上是一种精神和认知功能，它并不总是与我们的物理环境、我们看到的人以及我们生活中的人挂钩。你可以在一个巨大拥挤的房间里感到孤独。当你被你最爱的人包围时，你也会感到孤独，因为这是一种认知的想法，是对某种内在而非外在事物的认知反应。我认为保持这一点也很重要
our thresholds, our individual thresholds for loneliness are also very much subjective and based on our own personal needs for connection and with that social interaction as well. I know people in my life who don't need a lot of social interaction at all. They can see someone like once a week and that's all they need to feel happy and content and healthy. And then there's others such as myself who, you know, I'm not. I constantly need to be in contact with friends or family all the time. And even then I still feel alone sometimes.
我们对孤独的阈值，即个人阈值，在很大程度上也是主观的，是基于我们对联系以及随之而来的社交互动的个人需求。我认识生活中的一些人，他们根本不需要太多的社交互动。他们可能一周见某人一次，这就是他们感到快乐、满足和健康所需的全部。然后还有其他人，比如我自己，你知道的，我不是。我需要不断地与朋友或家人保持联系。即便如此，有时我还是觉得孤单。
Even when I've seen people, you know, earlier that day, or even now when I'm home with my family, it's this weird inexplicable sensation of having people around you and yet not feeling as connected as you hoped. And loneliness can happen whenever, whatever's happening. Whatever's happening around you. and even if you aren't feeling particularly socially isolated. And it does also have a pretty powerful mental impact on our health.
即使是在那天早些时候见过人之后，甚至像现在这样我回到家里和家人在一起时，这是一种奇怪而莫名其妙的感觉，身边的确有人，却没有产生你所希望的那种紧密的联系。无论发生什么，无论你周围发生什么，孤独都可能随时降临。即使你并没有感到特别的社交孤立。它确实对我们的健康有着相当强大的心理影响。
I think I did a whole episode about this. And it's so common in our 20s, right? We're trying to find our feet. We're trying to discover what our relationships mean to us and the people around us and we're shifting jobs. We're shifting from school and to work and moving out of home and losing friends and breaking out of home. and losing friends and breaking up with our partners for the first time,
我想我为此做了一整集的节目。这在我们的二十几岁时太常见了，对吧？我们正在努力站稳脚跟。我们试图弄清楚我们的关系对我们意味着什么，以及我们周围的人意味着什么，我们在换工作。我们从学校过渡到工作，搬出家门，失去朋友，打破家庭。失去朋友并与伴侣第一次分手，
it is, I think, a defining mechanism, a defining experience of this decade of our 20s. It's interesting, though, because a lot of the research that you will find on loneliness if you go digging for it, if you go looking for it, it centers a lot on older adults, on people who are elderly or living in nursing homes, despite the fact that I think you can feel lonely at any age. And our 20s are also a pretty defining decade, I'd say, for this feeling and for this experience. When you feel socially isolated, studies have shown that loneliness and the loneliness that you feel can be as painful and as impactful as if you were in physical pain or experiencing some form of physical trauma. I'm pretty sure we've all experienced this.
我认为，这是我们二十几岁这十年的一个决定性机制，一个决定性的经历。然而有趣的是，如果你去挖掘、去寻找，你会发现很多关于孤独的研究都集中在老年人身上，集中在老年人或住在疗养院的人身上，尽管事实上我认为你在任何年龄都会感到孤独。而且对于这种感觉和这种经历来说，我们的二十几岁也可以说是一个非常具有决定性的十年。当你感到社交孤立时，研究表明，孤独以及你感受到的孤独可以和你在经历身体疼痛或某种形式的身体创伤时一样痛苦、一样具有冲击力。我很确定我们都经历过这个。
you know, that tightness in our chest, that kind of coldish sting of feeling alone. And that feeling, that activates the same neurological pathways, the same parts of our brain that respond to physical pain. And of course it has an evolutionary explanation, right? We are tribal, social creatures. We're pack animals. and our survival in the past was dependent on being surrounded by others. You know, we could not go at the wilderness, go out life by ourselves.
你知道的，我们胸口的那种紧绷感，那种感到孤独的冰冷刺痛感。而那种感觉，会激活相同的神经通路，即我们大脑中对身体疼痛做出反应的相同部分。当然，这有一个进化的解释，对吧？我们是部落社会的生物。我们是群居动物。我们在过去的生存取决于被其他人包围。你知道的，我们无法独自走向荒野，独自度过一生。
We needed safety, insecurity and numbers so that people could help build shelters whilst others helped collect food and water and raise the children and provide security and protection from whatever was out there. So instinctually and naturally, nowadays, those parts of our brains, of course, still exist. And they're still going to react in the same way when we feel that we aren't surrounded by the people that we would like to be or when we feel alone. We're going to have that same instinctual reaction of like, oh my God, my survival is at risk. I need to find people to be around. I need to make my way back into the pack and back into the tribe in order to feel that safety and security.
我们需要靠数量来获得安全保障，以便人们能够互相帮助建造庇护所，同时其他人帮助收集食物和水，抚养孩子，并提供安全和保护，免受外面的任何威胁。因此，出于本能和自然，如今我们大脑的那些部分当然仍然存在。当我们在感觉自己没有被希望陪伴的人包围时，或者当我们感到孤独时，它们仍然会以同样的方式做出反应。我们将有那种相同的本能反应，就像，天哪，我的生存面临风险。我需要找到人陪伴。我需要回到族群和部落中去，以便感受到那种安全和保障。
That's an explanation for why loneliness can hurt so much. research is also shown that people who enjoy and have and cultivate strong social ties they actually tend to live longer on average it was four years longer and they also protect like our social relationships also protect against cognitive decline and mental deterioration because those parts of our brains that are activated when we socialize when we interact when we connect with someone else, when we can offer them empathy and share a really nice conversation, those parts of our brain are really important for our functioning in other areas of life. It's also interesting, they did this study on more than, I think, like 3,000 participants. And it showed that people who were lonely, especially when they were older,
这就是为什么孤独会如此痛苦的一个解释。研究还表明，那些喜欢、拥有并培养强大社交纽带的人，平均寿命往往更长。事实上，会长寿四年。它们还能保护我们的社交关系，免受认知衰退和精神退化的影响，因为我们大脑中那些在我们社交、互动、与他人建立联系、向他们提供同理心并进行真正美好对话时被激活的部分，对我们在生活其他领域的运作真的非常重要。同样有趣的是，他们对超过3000名参与者（我想是的）进行了这项研究。结果表明，感到孤独的人，尤其是年龄较大的人，
had a higher rate of dementia as well, which just proves that being, properly socially connected, whatever that means for you, is so valuable. I will also say that certain studies and research, they do suggest that loneliness every now and again may be a beneficial thing when it's in small doses. A bit of solitude is actually quite beneficial because it can allow us to prioritize and focus on the relationships that do matter to us. By recognizing I guess whose absence is most profound and hopefully giving that relationship more attention. A healthy dose of being alone as well I think is really beneficial for being able to focus inward without distractions, without people around us, without their opinions.
患痴呆症的比率也更高，这证明了保持适当的社交联系（无论这对你意味着什么）是多么有价值。我还要说的是，某些研究表明，偶尔感到孤独在小剂量下可能是一件有益的事情。一点点的独处其实是非常有益的，因为它可以让我们优先考虑并专注于那些对我们真正重要的关系。通过承认，我猜，谁的缺席是最深刻的，并希望给那种关系更多的投入。我也认为，健康的独处对于能够将注意力转向内，而不受干扰、没有我们周围的人、没有他们的意见是非常有益的。
And in those moments where we aren't, you know, being called one way or another by the people around us when we don't feel the need to constantly be talking to people or keeping up our social relationships, we can really uncover some of the issues that we've potentially been ignoring or even suppressing. And the time we end up spending alone with ourselves, I believe, is some of the most valuable, because we can honestly reflect, look inward, be frustrated with ourselves, be annoyed, but also be incredibly candid about what we want and who we would like to be. That being said, there is a time and a place for these experiences and the deep contemplation that's often brought forth by loneliness and the holidays.
在那些时刻，我们没有被周围的人以这样或那样的方式召唤，当我们觉得没有必要不断与人交谈或维持我们的社会关系时，我们真的可以发现一些我们可能一直在忽视甚至压抑的问题。我相信，我们最终花在与自己独处的时间是极其宝贵的，因为我们可以真诚地反思、向内看、对自己感到沮丧、感到恼火，但也能够极其坦诚地面对我们想要什么以及我们想成为什么样的人。话虽如此，这些经历以及由孤独和节日带来的深刻沉思，也有其时间和地点。
It's not always a pleasant experience, right? And it's not always the best time of the year when we are surrounded by joy and there is this expectation of seeing our families, feeling lonely, that period of solitude, it's perhaps not the greatest time to be having that feeling. Back to kind of that loneliness during the holidays, conundrum, that real focus of what we're talking about today. And there are so many factors that can contribute to this feeling during this time of the year. I honestly, I was trying to list some.
这并不总是一种愉快的经历，对吧？当我们被喜悦包围，且有一种见到家人的期望时，这并不总是一年中最好的时刻。感到孤独，那段独处期，也许并不是产生这种感觉的最佳时机。回到我们今天关注的核心——节日期间的孤独这个难题。在这个季节里，有太多的因素会导致这种感觉。老实说，我试着列举一些。
I was thinking them through all day to day today. trying to put my finger on it, and I don't actually think we can even start to cover them all in this episode. But the primary ones I think are important to discuss are, of course, firstly, are family relationships good or bad? Even the most perfect family dynamics, the most perfect family can be overwhelming after a while, especially if you're not used to having this kind of exposure or you're used to having an element of independence and you know you might live elsewhere and you're coming back for the holidays and christness is this like rapid and intense exposure to family and the family dynamics the history the chaos sometimes even the drama
我今天一整天都在思考它们。试图搞清楚这一点，但实际上我认为我们无法在本期节目中涵盖所有这些。但我认为重要的主要讨论点，当然，首先是，家庭关系是好是坏？即使是最完美的家庭动态，最完美的家庭，一段时间后也会让人感到不知所措，尤其是如果你不习惯这种接触，或者你习惯了一定程度的独立，你知道你可能住在别的地方，你为了过节回来，而圣诞节就像是对家庭和家庭动态、历史、混乱、有时甚至是戏剧的一种快速而激烈的接触，
and that can be not only quite exhausting but also kind of like frustrating and yeah really intense when you're used to the support of a family from a distance, and that exposure of that closeness doesn't always have the desired effect. And it can actually make us feel even more disconnected, because we're sitting amongst our family members, we're exposed to them in this really heightened intense environment, and we can just feel incredibly exhausted. And we really just want to shut down. We're not actually used to this. It can be so overwhelming. then of course there are those of us who may have a strained or even non-existent relationship with our family and this period can be especially difficult and almost beckon in a lot of loneliness and
这不仅会相当令人筋疲力尽，而且也会让人感到有点沮丧，是的，当习惯了与家人保持距离的支持时，这种接触确实非常强烈，这种亲密的接触并不总能达到预期的效果。它实际上会让我们感到更加脱节，因为我们坐在家庭成员中间，我们在这种高度紧张的环境中接触他们，我们会感到难以置信的筋疲力尽。而我们真的只想关闭自己。我们其实不习惯这样。这太让人应接不暇了。然后当然，我们当中有些人可能与家人的关系很紧张，甚至根本不存在，这个时期可能会特别困难，由于非常明显的原因，几乎会招致大量的孤独和
sadness for very obvious reasons so i think if that is you and you relate to that i'm sending you so much love, there really is no explanation I think that I can provide for this experience. And I hate when people say things like, oh, it makes you stronger or things happen for a reason. Just know that there are people who love you and I'm sending you strength for what I'm sure can be a really tough time. I think even if we do have a relationship with our family for the holidays and we are able to go and see them during this time, sometimes that can also be really strained. Or we We feel like there are elements of ourselves that we can't be completely honest about, or elements of ourselves which aren't going to receive the full respect that we really deserve,
悲伤。所以我想，如果你是这样的人，并且能对此感同身受，我向你发送满满的爱。我认为没有任何解释可以说明这种经历。我讨厌别人说“哦，这会让你变得更坚强”或“事情发生总有原因的”之类的话。只要知道有人爱你，我为你发送力量，度过我确信可能非常艰难的一段时光。我想，即使我们确实与家人维持着过节的关系，并且能够在这期间去看望他们，有时这种关系也可能会非常紧张。或者我们觉得我们身上的某些部分无法完全坦白，或者我们身上的某些部分无法得到我们真正应得的充分尊重，
especially when it comes to our families. Christmas, the holidays, whatever you celebrate. If it means exposure to family, it can sometimes mean concealing those elements and characteristics, and as a result feeling a lot less like ourselves and therefore more disconnected. And I think a final element that comes into this is if we're grieving someone. If this is your first Christmas without someone really important to you, I know this time can be particularly challenging, especially with that narrative and that emphasis on family and being surrounded
特别是在涉及我们的家庭时。圣诞节，节日，无论你庆祝什么。如果这意味着要与家人接触，有时就意味着要隐藏那些元素和特征，结果让我们感觉更不像自己，因此感到更加脱节。我认为其中包含的最后一个因素是，如果我们正在为某人悲伤。如果这是你没有了某个对你非常重要的人的第一个圣诞节，我知道这个时候会特别具有挑战性，尤其是伴随着那种叙事以及对家庭和被
by your loved ones. This time of the year is particularly hard. We feel this pressure to bring our loved ones close and to spend time with family, and not being able to do that for whatever reason, whether it's because of a separation or a death, or because of a strained relationship with our family, I think that, of course, is especially painful.
所爱的人包围的强调。一年的这个时候特别艰难。我们感到一种压力，要把我们所爱的人拉近，花时间陪伴家人，而无论出于何种原因无法做到这一点，无论是由于分离或死亡，还是由于与家人的紧张关系，我认为这当然是特别痛苦的。
And it's no wonder that if you are going through this situation, you might be feeling particularly lonely and particularly disconnected. I read this really interesting article when I was researching this. The holidays, they're actually often the hardest for those who don't have that reliable support system or who don't have access to family in the way that many of us do. This includes, I guess, all of those things we just talked about, people who've lost loved ones, maybe you have a strained relationship, an unexistent relationship, maybe you've had to put up a boundary like we talked about last week,
如果你正在经历这种处境，你可能会感到格外孤独和格外脱节，这也就不足为奇了。我在做研究时读到过一篇非常有趣的文章。节日，对于那些没有可靠支持系统或无法像我们许多人那样接触到家人的人来说，实际上往往是最艰难的。这包括，我猜，我们刚刚谈到的所有那些人，失去亲人的人，也许你有着紧张的关系，不存在的关系，也许你不得不设定一个界限，就像我们上周谈到的那样，
and that wasn't respected by your family members. and cutting off contact, not being in their life for the holiday season, was the only way to move forward. Additionally, the holidays, they're often full of these, you know, scenes everywhere we look, on social media, on the television of people spending really happy and joyous times with their family and friends, leading a lot of us, I think, or some of us, to feel like you're maybe the only one without someone in their life during this time. Of course, I know that's not the case, you know that's not the case, but it's all wrapped up in this idea of comparison.
而这并没有受到你家庭成员的尊重。切断联系，在节日期间不在他们的生活中，是继续前行的唯一途径。此外，节日期间往往充满了这些场景，无论我们走到哪里，在社交媒体上，在电视上，都能看到人们与家人和朋友度过非常快乐和欢乐的时光，导致我们很多人，或者我们中的一些人，觉得在这个时期，你可能是唯一一个生命中没有伴侣的人。当然，我知道事实并非如此，你知道事实并非如此，但这都包裹在比较的概念中。
The thing we all do, we all compare, and it's a huge contributor to loneliness in the holiday season. I want to talk a little bit more about comparison because I think it's really important when we talk about loneliness during the holiday season. This time is a time for oversharing. We see people in love, people traveling, people with their families. families and beautiful partners who they get to spend the holidays with. We see them in front of their Christmas tree with all their gifts and, you know, this big extended group of people. I think I've said it before, but I think it's important to stress again.
我们都会做的事情，我们都会进行比较，这是节日期间孤独的一个巨大贡献者。我想多谈谈比较，因为我认为当我们谈论节日期间的孤独时，这真的很重要。这个时候是一个过度分享的时期。我们看到人们恋爱，人们旅行，人们与家人在一起。家庭和漂亮的伴侣，他们可以一起度过节日。我们在他们的圣诞树前看到他们，带着所有的礼物和，你知道的，这个庞大的大家庭。我想我以前说过，但我认为再次强调这一点很重要。
In those instances, comparison is a real thief of joy here. It's honestly one of the phrases I live by after hearing it, I think a few years ago. and now I know personally, I say it to myself so much. You know, comparison is a thief of joy. But I know personally it can be such a challenge not to compare. You know, I just did a whole episode on this a few weeks ago. But especially at times like this, it's just so easy. It's everywhere you look.
在这些情况下，比较真的是快乐的小偷。老实说，这是我在几年前听到它之后赖以生存的短语之一。现在我知道就个人而言，我对自己说了无数次。你知道的，比较是快乐的小偷。但我个人知道，不进行比较可能是一个巨大的挑战。你知道的，几周前我才刚做了一整集关于这个的节目。但特别是在这样的时刻，这太容易了。你到处都能看到。
It's across billboards. It's literally everywhere. It's on our phones. It's in the conversations we have with colleagues. It's in the group chats that we're in. But comparison, it can exacerbate so much loneliness and so many insecurities we might already have. And with our lives often on display around the holiday season, with people, you know, sharing their home cooked meals and their trees and their gifts and their family, it can be especially hard to avoid this. And it, of course, can make us feel even more disconnected and can really heighten what might already be.
它在广告牌上。它真的无处不在。它在我们的手机里。它在我们与同事的对话中。它在我们所在的群聊中。但是比较，它会加剧很多孤独感和我们可能已经有的很多不安全感。随着我们的生活在节日期间经常被展示出来，人们（你知道的）分享他们自制的饭菜、他们的树木、他们的礼物和他们的家庭，避免这种比较可能特别困难。而且，它当然会让我们感到更加脱节，并且真的会加剧可能已经存在的情况。
a sense of judgment around what we don't have and a sense of our lives lacking. Of course, all of these factors, our family, our friends, our social environment are very pertinent, are very important to consider. But there are other elements of our environment, I think, also contribute to loneliness around this time, especially if you're living somewhere where it's really dark and cold during the holidays, seasonal, effective disorder, seasonal depression, it does not play around. And on top of many of these other factors and experiences, think, you know, that separation from family, there's financial, things to think about, there's the stress from the busyness of this year, our environment is obviously going
对我们所没有的东西的评判感，以及一种我们的生活有所欠缺的感觉。当然，所有这些因素——我们的家庭、我们的朋友、我们的社交环境——都是非常贴切的，对于考虑来说非常重要。但我想，我们环境的其他元素也对这个时候的孤独感有所贡献，特别是如果你住在节日期间又黑又冷的地方，季节性情感障碍，季节性抑郁，它可不是闹着玩的。除了许多其他因素和经历之外，我认为（你知道的）与家人的分离，有财务方面的事情要考虑，有今年忙碌带来的压力，我们的环境显然会
to play a huge part. And as we know, our environment is a massive determinant to our state of mind and our well-being. And often our mental state can mimic our external surroundings. So if you are already in a vulnerable state because you know that this year you don't get a go home, maybe you're working, because you have that strained relationship with your family, and then suddenly it's freezing cold and it's super dark and it just feels gross outside. I can imagine all of those factors really play on top of each other. They play into each other and create that feeling of loneliness that has been, you know, the point of this discussion. another one that's really interesting for me that someone I know actually brought up was that when
发挥巨大的作用。正如我们所知，我们的环境是我们精神状态和福祉的巨大决定因素。而且我们的精神状态往往可以模仿我们外部的环境。因此，如果你已经处于脆弱的状态，因为你知道今年你不能回家，也许你在工作，因为你与家人的关系很紧张，然后突然天气变得冰冷，天色超级黑，外面感觉糟透了。我可以想象所有这些因素真的叠加在一起。它们相互交织，创造了那种一直是（你知道的）这次讨论重点的孤独感。另一个对我很感兴趣的话题，实际上是我认识的一个人提出的，那就是当
we go home for the holidays or when we travel or we're going to see family there is this loss of consistency in the habits and the lifestyle that we normally keep and a kind of a disruption to the peace and normalcy of everyday life I find this when I come home right like I'm used to waking up at a certain time getting to choose or what I want to do, when I want to do it, being able to see my friends. You know, none of my friends live, you know, only a couple of them actually live where my parents live. So it's like an immediate, you know, seven day period of time where the only social connection I have in person is my family. And that is so disruptive. And I always think like, oh, what's going on without me?
我们为了过节回家，或者当我们旅行或去看望家人时，我们平时保持的习惯和生活方式的consistency（连贯性）会丧失，日常生活的平静和正常状态也会受到干扰。我每次回家时都会发现这一点，对吧？我习惯了在某个时间醒来，能够选择我想做什么，什么时候做，能够去见我的朋友。你知道的，我的朋友没有一个（你知道的）只有一小部分实际上住在我的父母住的地方。所以这就变成了一个直接的（你知道的）为期七天的时期，我唯一亲自进行的社交联系就是我的家庭。这是如此具有颠覆性。我总是想，哦，没有我的时候发生了什么？
Like I get this almost fomo. And then I feel guilt. I'm like, oh, I haven't seen my family in so long. I want to be spending time with them. I love them. I enjoy their company. But I'm also used to having the life that I have that is separate from them. And when the holidays come around, it's this kind of big disruption to that. And I have to recalibrate so much of my life to adapt to this weird period in which everything gets put on pause. I think also there can many times during this period be these. unrealistic expectations and memories, this nostalgia. And I think nostalgia is one of the most beautiful parts about being human. Like, it's incredible that we can reflect on beautiful times in our
就像我有这种几乎是错失恐惧症（fomo）。然后我感到内疚。我想，哦，我好久没见家人了。我想花时间陪他们。我爱他们。我喜欢他们的陪伴。但我也习惯了拥有与他们分开的生活。当节日到来时，这对那种生活是一个相当大的干扰。我必须重新调整我生活的很大一部分，以适应这个奇怪的时期，在这个时期，一切都被按下了暂停键。我也认为在这个时期，很多时候可能会有这些不切实际的期望和记忆，这种怀旧情绪。而且我认为怀旧是作为人类最美丽的部分之一。就像，我们能够反思我们生命中的美好时光并感受到那些相同的感受和那些相同的感官，这真是不可思议。就像，这简直太棒了。但这肯定也伴随着它的缺点，特别是当我们想到过去节日或过去圣诞节等的记忆时，在那些记忆中，你确实得以与亲人一起庆祝，一切都进行得很完美，你知道的，你得以见到所有你爱的人，并与你的朋友和家人共度时光，也许今年情况并非如此，事情发生了，你无法与他们亲近，你无法赶回去，也许你不再与你的家庭有那种关系，你负担不起那次旅行，回想那些情况完美、你能够创造这些记忆的时刻，可能会更加
lives and feel those same feelings and those same sensations. Like, that's just wonderful. But it also comes with its downsides for sure, particularly when we think about memories of past holidays or past Christmases or whatever, where you did get to celebrate with loved ones and everything went perfectly and you know you got to see everyone that you loved and spend time with your friends and your family and maybe this year that wasn't the case things came up you weren't able to be close with them you weren't able to make it back maybe you don't have that relationship with your family anymore you can't afford to make that trip and thinking back on those times when the situation was perfect when you were able to make those memories can be even more
困难。我认为通常当我们无法与朋友和家人聚在一起时，它会让我们更加怀念过去。我们会想起那些一切都不同的旧时光，这会让我们感到相当沮丧和非常不高兴，特别是当我们想象我们可能正在经历的这种孤独感会持续下去时，我们知道它不会。它不会永远持续下去。但这说起来容易。这对我来说说起来容易。而要相信这一点则是完全不同的事情。最后，节日期间的孤独，为什么会发生？通常是因为这是一个反思的时刻。在节日期间，我们经常从大学和工作中获得假期。这是一个休息的时期。一切都处于暂停状态。随之而来的是缺乏让我们保持忙碌的事情。
difficult. I think often when we're unable to get together with friends and family, it can make us even more nostalgic. And we remember these old times when everything was different and it can make us feel pretty down and pretty unhappy, especially when we imagine that this loneliness that we might be feeling will persist, which we know it won't. It's not going to last forever. But it's very easy to say that. It's very easy for me to say that. And it's a very different thing to believe. that. And finally, loneliness during the holidays, why does it happen? Often because it's a time to reflect. During the holiday period, we often get leave from university and work. It's a period of rest. Everything's on pause. And with that comes a lack of things to keep us occupied.
当我们想到我们的日常生活时，有太多的事情让我们的头脑忙碌。你知道的，你有工作，你必须去大学，你必须跟上你的朋友，你必须跟上健身房或跟上你的爱好。有这么多的事情，这么多在我们的脑海里的事情。但当这些事情确实被按下暂停键，例如在此期间，它们消失了，我们不再有这种分心，并且我们认识到这可能实际上可能就是它们本来的面目——一种分心，
When we think about our everyday lives, there is so much to busy our minds with. You know, you've got work, you've got to go to uni, you've got to keep up with your friends, you've got to keep up with the gym or keep up with your hobbies. And there's so many things, so many things that are on our mind. But when those things do go on pause, such as during this period, and they disappear, we no longer have that distraction and we recognize that that's may have maybe actually what they are, a distraction
转移了我们内心一些更深层、更真实的感受。在这段时期里，在节日期间，那些我们一直压抑的感受以全速卷土重来。这就导致了一些不适和孤独感。
from what some of our deeper and truer feelings may be. And in this period, around the holidays, those very feelings that we've suppressed, they come back in full force. And that results in some of that discomfort and loneliness.
这是我在写今天的节目时考虑到的一个关键点。当然，我们不能在不谈论期望的情况下谈论这种孤独的经历、这种感觉。以及贯穿这段时间的外部期望，对快乐和感恩的炒作，你知道的，它无处不在，一年中最美好的时光，一个充满欢乐、感恩、爱和家庭的时刻。而在这个期望中隐含着这样一点：如果你不能有这种感觉，如果你在挣扎，如果你真的只是没有这种感觉，如果你远离你的
That's a key point that I was thinking about when I was writing today's episode. Of course, we cannot talk about this experience of loneliness, this sensation, without talking about expectations. And the external expectations placed on us throughout this time, the hype to be happy and to be grateful, you know, it's everywhere, the most wonderful time of the year, a time of joy and gratitude and love and family. And implicit within that expectation is that if you cannot feel that way if you are struggling, if you are really just not feeling it, if you're away from your
家人和朋友，如果你感到孤独，或者也许你只是希望有个人陪，你有点像个怪杰。我看到了。它无处不在。它无处不在。它在电影中。它在我们周围讲述的叙事中，即节日应该像一年中的任何其他时间一样狂欢。这会带来，这会给我们带来这么多的压力。所以即使你在挣扎，即使你真的没有过得很开心。这会让你感到那么多的内疚和羞耻。这会让你觉得你才是问题所在，因为这种叙事正在每个平台上被推崇，要快乐，要感恩。老实说，有人需要为那些独自过节的人写一张圣诞专辑。就像，我们需要改变叙事。或者像
family and friends, if you're feeling alone, or maybe you just wish you had somebody, you're a bit of a grinch. I see this. It's everywhere. It's everywhere. It's in movies. It's in the narrative told around us that the holiday should be reveled, like no other time of the year. And that is going to put, that place is so much pressure on us. So even if you are struggling, even if you are just really not having a great time. It's going to make you feel so much guilt and shame. And it's going to make it feel like you are the problem because this narrative is being pushed across every platform to be happy and to be grateful. Honestly, someone needs to write a Christmas album for those who are spending the holidays alone. Like, we need to change the narrative. Or like
也许是一部悲伤的浪漫喜剧，或者只是一部普通的浪漫喜剧，你在其中只是一个快乐的单身人士，无法回家过节，我不知道，你给自己买了一个家庭装的烤土豆和一瓶酒。就像这只是另一天一样。就像，霍尔马克（Hallmark），版权是可用的。你需要买这部电影。我老实说它会大卖，因为这对我们许多人来说就是这样，对许多人来说就是这样。就像，这根本不是一个特殊的时刻。每个人都告诉我们，由于我们讨论的所有这些原因，它应该是这样的。
maybe a sad rom-com or just a normal rom-com where you are just a happy single person who can't make it home for the holidays and I don't know, you buy yourself like a family-sized potato bake and a bottle of wine. Like it's just another day. Like, hallmark, the rights are available. You need to buy this movie. I honestly think it would sell because that is the case for so many of us, for so many people. Like, this is just not a special time. Like, everyone is telling us that it should be for all of those reasons that we've discussed.
由于种种原因，你知道的，这里已经有一种抑郁感。以及缺乏让我们分心的事物，以及这些需要变得惊艳的期望。然后你将它与环境因素结合起来，或者你可能不亲近你的家人，你知道的，家庭是这个季节的支柱。对于我们许多人来说，这一切都被包裹在这种脱节感中。也许它甚至导致你对节日季节感到畏惧。这种外部甚至内部的期望让情况变得更糟。那么我们能做些什么呢？
For so many reasons, like, there's already this sense of, I think, depression. and this lack of things to distract us and these expectations that this needs to be amazing. And then you combine that with like the environmental factors or the fact that you may be not close to your family, you know, the family being the pillar of this season. And it all just kind of gets wrapped up in this feeling of disconnection for many of us. And maybe it even results in you dreading the holiday season. That external and even internal expectation making it so much worse. So what can we do?
出于很多原因，比如说，人们已经有一种抑郁的情绪，缺乏能分散我们注意力的事情，并且对这个节日有着必须过得精彩的期待。然后你把这些与环境因素结合起来，或者结合你可能与家人并不亲密这一事实——你知道的，家人是这个节日的支柱。这一切对我们许多人来说，最终都包裹在一种疏离感中。这甚至可能导致你对假期感到恐惧。这种来自外部甚至内部的期待让情况变得更糟。那么我们能做些什么呢？
If you are feeling this way right now, if you're coming out of Christmas and just feeling really down about yourself and just feeling a little bit lost, a little bit lonely, I think the first thing to do is just to find that, you know, whatever it is, the small joys that give you meaning. And the things that you can enjoy about this, time, whether it is the holiday time if you are someone who is on leave at the moment, or it's the cookies and the food and the crappy movies and, you know, the opportunity to buy yourself
如果你现在有这种感受，如果你刚过完圣诞节，就对自己感到很沮丧，觉得有点迷茫、有点孤独，我觉得首先要做的就是去寻找那些能给你带来意义的小确幸。无论是什么，在这个时期你能享受的事物，不管是假期——如果你现在正好在休假，或者是曲奇饼干、美食、烂电影，以及有机会给自己买
a really expensive, ridiculous gift because it's Christmas and because it's the holidays. Whatever you need, you can take advantage or whatever best serves you if it means that you're going to feel better about this season and if it's going to curb some of your loneliness. I think it's also important to think and plan ahead about what there is to look forward to when everything kind of comes back to normal. Maybe it's about planning a trip or planning something important for you, maybe a concert, something that you can look forward to so that you don't get, I think, stuck in the sadness of this period or the loneliness.
一件非常昂贵、离谱的礼物，因为今天是圣诞节，因为这是假期。无论你需要什么，只要能让你在这个季节感觉更好一点，能缓解你的孤独感，你都可以去利用，去做最适合你的事。我觉得同样重要的是，提前思考和规划当一切恢复正常时，有什么值得期待的事情。也许是计划一次旅行，或者为自己规划一些重要的事情，比如一场音乐会，一些你可以期待的事情，这样你就不会陷入这段时期的悲伤或孤独之中。
And coming into both of those points, like treat yourself. honestly do it. There is nothing that a little dopamine hit from some retail therapy or some like yummy food or whatever. A little gift isn't going to help with. It's honestly a real thing. You've got to sometimes be the one to reward yourself, especially if you're spending the holidays alone. This is a great time to be able to parent yourself and treat yourself the way that you would want to be treated as if you were a child, like treat yourself to the experiences that you would want to have at this time because you really are the person who's in control of your happiness for most of the part. You know, not all of it.
顺着这两点来说，就是对自己好一点。说真的，去做吧。通过血拼来一次多巴胺刺激，或者吃点美味的食物之类的，没有什么是一个小礼物解决不了的。这绝对是真实存在的。有时候你必须成为那个奖励自己的人，特别是当你独自过节的时候。这是一个很好的机会，你可以像父母一样关爱自己，用你希望被对待的方式来对待自己——就像你还是个孩子一样，让自己享受你在这个时期想拥有的体验，因为在很大程度上，你真的是自己幸福的掌控者。当然，并非全部。
There are obviously other factors, but our happiness is very much in our control when we get to decide our environment and what we give to ourselves. Of course, I also think it's important to text, call, reach out to the people that do make you feel seen and connected. Reach out to them. I'm sure they would love to hear from you. And it's a way of allowing yourself to acknowledge that there are people who care about you. You're not alone, even if so many aspects of this season try and convince us that we are,
显然还有其他因素，但我们的幸福很大程度上掌握在自己手中，因为我们可以决定自己的环境以及我们给予自己什么。当然，我也觉得很重要的一点是，去给那些真正让你感到被关注、被连接的人发信息、打电话、联系他们。联系他们吧。我确信他们会很乐意听到你的消息。这也是一种让自己认识到有人在乎你的方式。你并不孤独，即使这个季节的很多方面都在试图说服我们是孤独的，
and that they are there for you. And there are people that love you. I think it's also just a great way just to get some of that social connection and social interaction that can often curb our loneliness. get off social media. This is like the biggest tip. When it's the holiday time, I honestly cannot be on social media. I get so much FOMO. I'm constantly comparing myself. I literally, it's so overwhelming. I cannot deal with it. Everyone's on their vacations and having the best time and getting the best Christmas gifts and have this beautiful relationship or this beautiful family. and I know that for me comparison, like I said, is the thief of joy.
而且他们一直都在支持你。总有人爱着你。我也觉得这只是获得社交连接和社交互动的一个绝佳方式，这通常能抑制我们的孤独感。远离社交媒体。这绝对是最大的建议。在假期里，我老实说真的无法使用社交媒体。我会产生极强的错过恐惧症（FOMO）。我一直在拿自己作比较。我简直……这太让人崩溃了。我根本应付不来。每个人都在度假，过得无比开心，收到最好的圣诞礼物，拥有美满的感情或美满的家庭。而我知道，对我来说，正如我所说，比较是快乐的小偷。
So I make a conscious decision to stay away for as much as I can allow myself to and just put an end to that before it even begins. And I use this time instead to rest and relax. Rest and relax when you can. We are so much better able to navigate these feelings of isolation, of loneliness, of feeling a little bit crap. when we have the mental resources we need at our disposal, including a well-rested mind.
所以我做出有意识的决定，在自己允许的范围内尽可能远离它，在它开始之前就制止它。相反，我利用这段时间来休息和放松。在可以的时候休息和放松。当我们拥有所需的精神资源（包括一个得到充分休息的大脑）时，我们能更好地应对这些孤立感、孤独感以及这种糟糕的感觉。
It's so much better for our cognitive state when we feel well-rested, when we have the energy to ward off some of these negative feelings. Distract yourself if you have to as well. Just go outside, do some shopping, see a friend if you're able to watch Emily in Paris. I don't know, I just saw that that came out. I may have binge-watched it. It's very fun. anything that will allow you to find those small moments and the small things to be grateful for and those small distractions.
当我们感到休息充分、有足够的精力去抵御这些负面情绪时，这对我们的认知状态要好得多。如果必须的话，也可以转移一下注意力。只要去户外走走，去购购物，如果可以的话去见个朋友，看看《艾米丽在巴黎》。我不知道，我刚看到这部剧上线了。我可能一口气把它看完了。非常有趣。任何能让你找到那些小瞬间、值得感恩的小事物以及小小 distractions（分心）的事情都可以。
And if you are someone who spent the holidays alone and you're listening to this and relating to this, I just want to say, I think you're doing an amazing job. I don't want to say I'm sorry. I feel like pity is such a terrible feeling to have lobbied at you. But I just think that you deserve a lot of credit. I know it can be really, really difficult to go through this period by yourself. Even for those of us who are surrounded by family, you know, some of those things we talked about are so real. There is this disruption to our daily habits.
如果你是一个人过节，正在听这期节目并感同身受，我只想说，我觉得你做得棒极了。我不想说“我很抱歉”。我觉得同情是一种很糟糕的强加给你的感觉。但我只是觉得你值得很多的认可。我知道独自度过这段时期真的非常非常不容易。即使对于我们这些被家人环绕的人来说，你知道的，我们讨论的一些事情也是如此真实。我们的日常习惯被打乱了。
We don't get to see our friends. We're kind of in this state where we don't have those distractions that we normally have. Or maybe you're just looking around and everyone seems to have a perfect relationship. They have someone to spend the holidays with or they have this perfect family. and you don't. And comparison is really your enemy in those moments. It's so much easier said than done, but whatever you can do to try and interrupt or disrupt that nasty little comparative beast, I think we're all better for it. That's all I have for you today. I just want to say thank you so much for listening to the Christmas special. Thank you so much for supporting the show this year.
我们见不到朋友。我们处在这样一种状态中，没有了平时那些分散注意力的东西。或者也许你只是环顾四周，每个人似乎都有一段完美的感情。他们有人陪着过节，或者有一个完美的家庭。而你没有。在那些时刻，比较真的是你的大敌。说起来容易做起来难，但无论你能做些什么来试图打断或干扰那个讨厌的小比较怪兽，我觉得对我们大家都有好处。这就是我今天要分享的全部内容。我只想说非常感谢大家收听圣诞特辑。非常感谢大家今年对节目的支持。
Oh my God, it's been insane. Next week, we are kicking a lot of. off the start of my New Year's series. So the next three episodes are all going to be around creating the best version of yourself for 2023 and how some of the psychology can explain things like New Year's resolutions, how to have a mental glow up, how to choose the love that you deserve, how to let go of the things that do not serve you. So I'm so excited. I've been doing so much planning and so much research and it's just incredible. And it's just incredible. And it's If you do feel called to do so, if you did enjoy this episode, please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts, Spotify Podcasts,
天哪，这太疯狂了。下周，我们要正式开启我的新年系列节目了。所以接下来的三期节目都将围绕着如何为2023年打造最好的自己展开，心理学如何解释新年愿望之类的事情，如何进行精神蜕变，如何选择你应得的爱，以及如何放手那些不再对你有益的事物。所以我超级兴奋。我一直在做大量的规划和研究，这简直太不可思议了。如果你愿意的话，如果你喜欢这期节目，请随时在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）、Spotify播客上留下五星好评，
wherever you are listening, and make sure to follow us at That Psychology Podcast. Thank you again, and I will see you later this week. I'll see you next week for a new episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
无论你在哪里收听，并且一定要在“That Psychology Podcast”上关注我们。再次感谢大家，我们这周晚些时候见。下周的新节目再见。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，
I break down the science of mental. mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me.
我剖析了精神坚韧、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养韧性的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。也就是IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方的TWA%（注：ASR原文如此）。在《Look Back at It》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我的一个重大时刻。
84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year.
84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一期节目中，我们都会选择一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何度过那段时期的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。那真是疯狂的一年。那真是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，大家最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人克尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hardway》。这个空间关乎黑男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方说其实都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做，在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hardway》。
In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of bothering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控骚扰双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证真人。本集暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。